thank you to Erin and Cara may wherever
you are for for all the heavy lifting on
organizing this site i know it's often a
logistical nightmare to let's put these
things together and it's come off
incredibly smoothly so i know that that
doesn't happen without a lot of hard
work so thank you so I'm so I culture I
for those who had tuned in last week I
didn't give a much of a brief in terms
of where all this work is coming from by
training I'm a molecular and population
ecologist and spent most of my graduate
years and early part of my career
academic career dealing and still do
actually half there's a whole another
research program that i'm not going
talking in a load that's field-based and
we spent most of our time and continue
to spend a lot of our time on the issues
around aquaculture the ecological issues
notably recently we've wrapped up a
number of your studies on sea lice we
continue on with escapes pollution of
various forms etc etc and it became
increasingly frustrating and challenging
as Anna college' Streck igniting that
while the amount of information
continued to build pointing you would
think any dispassionate decision maker
towards a particular direction no action
based on science was ever taken and now
frankly I don't expect a whole lot of
sort of science-based directing to to
occur and well how do we how do we break
this law job how do we how do we start
to to better understand what the issues
are and actually provide policy relevant
information and I began to to thank you
the the classical triple bottom line and
how do we how do we line up all of those
things in the in the context of
aquaculture and I realize the first
thing that needed to be done and
surprisingly hadn't been done up until
that point it was a baseline of
aquaculture performance and this is what
led to this gappy idea that
that you guys I believe have read a
little bit about the global aquaculture
Performance Index it was this this
initiative to try and and put a baseline
of performance of so the global marine
fin fish production and allow us to to
start talking apples and apples oranges
and oranges outside of this species
produced in this place and kind of
encapsulate the discussion that way this
is not this this work did not happen in
a vacuum at uvic it required a number of
people we had expert workshops conducted
throughout North America on particular
issues and how do we how do we deal with
how do we measure impacts of parasites
and diseases for example not
particularly simple or straightforward
exercise and what's more gabby is the
the aquaculture mariculture specific
application of epi which was born here
the environmental performance index with
colleagues at columbia university so
this is so something of a homecoming for
for gabby's back to its its its its
academic homeland and so what we did was
was took what i found to be a really
engaging and and powerful analytical
foundation and then apply it in and
tweak the the tool somewhat and apply it
in america mariculture context and so
that's what we've done so to give a
little bit more background on on this
and why we did it we're aiming at north
american western european markets and
granted when you look at this this
breakout marine finfish aplicar doesn't
represent a large proportion of global
aquaculture activity but in terms of the
markets that we seek to affect North
America Western Europe marine
aquaculture products do play a dominant
role in those marketplaces and so we
thought that this was a reasonable place
to start
how do we decide what species are
included and what species are not is
that we want to include all of the
species necessary to capture ninety
percent or more of the global population
and so that equaled out to to be 20
species and then how many countries
didn't do we include with this so if a
species is produced in 20 countries then
do we need to assess that species in 20
countries know how many countries do we
need to capture ninety percent of the
production of that species okay so we
have to decision rules for for inclusion
unless more we wanted to focus on
outcomes on actual performance on the
water which was something of a novel
perspective and to this day actually
remain somewhat novel as opposed to
theoretical best-case scenarios best
practices qualitative aspirational kind
of goals all very well and good but we
wanted to know what's going on on the
water today and we use the the proximity
to target methodology which will briefly
touch on in a moment so to then actually
do the assessments we had a number of
other decision rules that we wanted to
to keep to obviously the indicators that
we were going to use had to be relevant
they had to to actually be directly
attributable to environmental
sustainability like ice all ready said
they have to be performance-oriented not
aspirational or qualitative some that
they actually be measurable transparency
whenever you're doing anything that has
winners and losers potentially
transparency is absolutely fundamental
otherwise you know you will very quickly
be engaged in firefights one way or
another and so everything we've done is
and continues to be transparent ll raw
data all the way through all the
analyses are available on the web and
this also is really important too
because as soon as we've started
generating results and the losers quite
predictably said oh damn it you know
you've got it all wrong the wall
maybe we do here is our data here's our
analysis show us you know what what have
we missed and in a couple of cases we
actually did near there were mistakes
and we gained a certain amount of
credibility in the eyes of those who are
done wrong by saying you absolutely will
correct it and did everything we could
to try and make it right the majority of
time though the conversation ended there
and you know that was the last week we
heard of it except in the case of a
couple of supermarkets who still want to
sue us but we'll get to that in a minute
and data quality goes without saying we
need the everybody eats the best the
best quality data one can find and so we
engage in a pilot project we went out
and said okay here are sort of
coarse-grained issues of we're going to
how we're going to assess this what do
we actually assess and we did a pilot
project where we went out and looked at
36 of the major seafood sustainable
seafood initiatives out there and asked
what are the issues that all these
different various organizations buyer
guides etc are looking at and a set of
indicators popped up again and again and
again and those were the ones that we
decided to to go at they had passed
something of a peer review by virtue of
the fact of showing up excuse me again
then again and again like a escapes
right no matter who's buyer guide or
what you look at escapes is always an
issue when it comes to aquaculture so
therefore okay escapes has to be
included here so when we did all that we
came up with these ten indicators and
come on in no gone wait up with these
ten indicators and I don't think any of
them are particularly surprises we broke
them out into sort of functional groups
inputs discharges or outputs and then
those things that once released
continues to grow evolve change become a
moving target so
of course you know you could conceivably
measure hundreds of things if you look
at the WWF buyers guides or standards
program that that they're coming out
with now literate for salmon there's a
hundred and twenty seven different items
that anybody who wants to get that logo
on their product needs to needs to meet
this in some eyes is perhaps a little
over the top we decided you know we
could measure a hundred different things
if we wanted but these are the ten core
elements and so something like a Zagat's
guide or consumers reports where I don't
need to know everything about it i'm
looking for the key things that are
going to separate the better products
from the worst products keeping it
simple that's essentially what what
we've done you've seen the document
you've seen this you know particularly
complicated set of equations we don't
need to go into it though we can if
you're interested there's a tremendous
amount of sort of heavy lifting embedded
in this to get the data together and
then do the analysis and come to some
kind of conclusion and then the you know
how do we conclude is also another fat
sticky point we have a raid
environmental performances that that we
could we could measure against and you
know we have a lie we didn't want to get
into the situation of defining a a
particular line and we're not a standard
write some standards they set the bar
quite high others said it quite low and
we wanted to to say you know what we're
not interested in pointing to your
sustainable you're not we're trying to
develop a tool that is separating out
the players in a pool of players and say
who is better than than the others and
so we're setting a
admittedly impossible goldmark goalpost
of zero impact and it doesn't matter
that nobody no product in the world can
know manufactured product anyway can
meet this goal post that doesn't matter
it is an invariant no matter how how a
technology improves and how efficient
things get and all the rest of it zero
impact will never be met so therefore it
will always be a goalpost against which
we can measure and we're simply asking
how far is the product from that
particular goal post right and so we've
got here a couple of of salmon products
and the Norwegian products 472 it's
slightly closer to that zero impact than
the Chilean product and you know that's
interesting and in and of itself but
because we have a standard set of
metrics and applications we can begin
making cross-species comparison so in
this case we've got amberjack Chinese
and Japanese product it you're looking
at at the comparison within this species
why is the Japanese product scoring
better than the Chinese product right
that's sort of a policy relevant point
right there but even more interesting in
the real novel application of this is
we've now got a tool that we can compare
apples and apples oranges and oranges
across two different species grown well
in many parts of the world under in some
cases quite different types of condition
and we can on the same playing field
make a determination around the relative
performance of these various products
the leading or the number one top
performer was chinook salmon coming out
of coming out of New Zealand and this
spider diagram you see on the Left
depicts the performance in each of those
issue categories the grade in area in
the center represents the average
performance of all products in the world
and then the blue line traces the plot
for New Zealand salmon and so the score
of 73 is the area encapsulated by that
blue line now you can get to 73 by
almost you know innumerable combinations
of moving that line around right
covering the same area so what's
particularly interesting here is it
points out where things are really good
and where there is opportunity for
change for example in feed you can see
it meets about the the global average
for for all species and that is a
reflection of chinook salmon
particularly in the New Zealand market
being relatively new product only being
a few generations removed from wild
stock and therefore has not been gone
through the number of generations of
selective breeding to optimize feed
conversion ratios and so forth so if we
look at Atlantic salmon on the same plot
you'd see a better score there but worse
and in other areas and then we compare
now we've got to lay a product of of
chinook salmon to to compare and we can
see why New Zealand sits out on top
relative to Chile and we can make
comparisons against the the other
species which sits at the bottom of the
ranking the bottom of the class which is
grouper and even so no matter where you
grow grouper it's a bit of a nightmare
you can see even within the grouper
category there is some quite variable
performance
yes yeah so just to show where where
that particular product lay in reference
to a global mean okay so you know a
grouper is not a grouper for so for the
first time we can start teasing out for
example for Indonesian grouper VOD
biological oxygen demand or organic
pollution is a much bigger problem in
Indonesia than it is for the other areas
and so if we have limited resources that
we can apply to trying to get Indonesian
group or production up to some sort of
standard level then bo.d might be an
area where you know it's a low-hanging
fruit we can make some some achievable
gains quite quickly simply by looking at
other jurisdictions and copying what
they're doing and so we've got our
indicators we generate a species country
score what I've discussed so far is the
normalized score and that is the
performance per metric ton we very
quickly realized that that that score
though is ecologically irrelevant
because the ecology of the receiving
environment of the ecology period
doesn't matter doesn't respond to the
performance per metric ton at only
responds to the cumulative performer the
cumulative production and so we
generated another set of scores which
was the cumulative species country
scores and broke them out in terms of
species in kg so so when you start
flipping through that dr. you're
basically awash in scores and I
appreciate the fact that it can be
challenging to follow something through
from beginning to end knowing that we've
got four different flavors of scores
coming at the other end but from an
ecological point of view or
sustainability point of view it actually
makes surprising amount of difference
and so here's the sort of busy one of
the busy results of that remembering
that we're on a 0 to 100 scale so the
taller the bar the better normalized
school
are in red cumulative score in green and
then the square is the little orange
squares represent the the production
assessed so a couple of things jump out
at you pretty quick we have numerous
examples where we've got very high
normalized scores but are countered with
very low cumulative scores right so
Norway being kind of the textbook
example there atlantic salmon and Norwin
norwegian production is dominated almost
hourly there's some cod couple of
species in there but it's mostly
atlantic salmon score 72 on average but
drop to 34 as a result driven largely by
that square way up at the top which
denotes a tremendously large production
and then we can contrast that with
Australian France that tend to be
characterized by growing really
problematic species these are the
ecological point of view these are
tremendously expensive species but
because their production is so small
their cumulative score actually rises to
the top so the take home message here is
that you know it doesn't matter how bad
a farm is maybe you can have the worst
farm in the world if there's this one of
them the total ecological impact is
rather modest as opposed to you can have
really highly efficient farms but if
you've got thousands of them like they
do in Norway right that's a problem
potentially right we can also rank them
according to species so in descending
descending normalized Mercer a
cumulative first know what if I here so
yeah you can get mixed up descending
yeah he's sending normalized scores so
surprisingly you know the sand is say it
up here if you go to bc you know
Atlantic salmon are right next to you
know the devil in terms of of impact
right and and so we caught a fair bit of
flack from our our friends in the NGO
community by giving what they saw as a
free pass to salmon and you know as I
need not explain to you you know there's
very little black and white in any in
any of these stories and the real
interesting parts are in the gray and
this is this is no exception and so if
we take those scores and then plot them
scores per metric ton total productions
for cumulative impact scores we get this
array of of players and down in the in
the bottom here we've got so this is
these are the players who score poorly
per metric ton and poorly cubital these
are the worst of the worst and they tend
to be the youngest industries so the
colors actually represent the age of the
industry of the number of years these
products have been in production in
these countries and aquaculture is a
trial-and-error kind of activity like
you know many industries particularly in
the early phases and air actually
manifests as ecological impact the
intermediate where we've got the
intermediate age and also intermediate
scores and then interestingly when we
get down to these guys so we've got high
per ton scores but low cumulative scores
Atlantic salmon being here milk fish and
in Geneva a few others right these are
the ones that have actually grown in
response to becoming efficient this is
what I was getting at last weekend in
that lecture this double-edged nature of
efficiencies that it is because of this
high score actually drives down or your
provides economic incentive to engage in
more and more production of these things
and then that drives down the cumulative
score and then finally you know the
fastest growing ones also happened to be
the most problematic and so
he'll that in a nutshell is where we
ended up with with the gap e program we
we then had a so we had this baseline of
performance around the world and it
became your not surprisingly obvious
that but you know this is a really
complicated issue and you know we you
and we research we live this stuff and
were our head is spilling so imagine
what it's like trust trying to be a
consumer who walks into the supermarket
and says you know I'm trying to buy
something that I can look in the mirror
you know after i eat it and you'll not
be disgusted with myself and so as a
result you know what I call the
sustainable seafood industry has arisen
with you know great great vigor and all
of these things are the labels a lot of
them consumer facing that are geared to
try and remove the the difficult
calculus out of trying to buy a
sustainable seafood for dare and we
started looking at it and wondered well
we've got this baseline of conventional
production I wonder what it would look
like if we started assessing these
products produced under the constraints
that one would have to meet to achieve
one of these labels right and so this is
another another product that we produced
how green is a Rico label and we asked a
fairly simple question what is the
minimum environmental performance to
require to meet one of these
certification levels and so you can
imagine you know here's our gappy score
0 to 100 imagine some theoretical
product the score 70 normally and then
under some label be it organic label and
industry label some kind of
sustainability label its score rises to
81 and so it has a value added of 11
points right so 11 is our is our metric
it's the value of the label
here we have our series of labels and
they're ordered from highest-performing
to two lowest performing in absolute
terms after the very top is the US
National Organic standard for salmon it
is so far a draft standard hasn't been
enacted in and you know me the industry
has come back and said well quite quite
strongly that it is a standard that
cannot be achieved I guess we'll we'll
wait and see things get really
interesting when we start looking ok
there's the absolute values but what do
they represent in terms of value added
to the products they seek to to endorse
and so not surprising the US natural
organic standard sits up top
representing 21 points above the average
the average product and again it's
dominated mostly by by salmon we've got
a couple other interesting Australia
organic sets of sets a pretty high
value-added mostly because Australia is
dominated by such terrible species right
that any step in in in an ecologically
minded way is going to result in a
significant improvement over what is
largely a deeply problematic mera
culture industry with the exception of
those couple of the top we get very very
modest return sitting usually 12 points
statistically I would venture these are
not these are not statistically
different from 0 in fact we have quite a
number of zeros and then we have so
marks and sparks marks and spencers
actually their their label their store
label set a bar 10 points below average
production for this a salmon average net
pen production of salmon hence the
lawsuit
this got picked up by the Guardian The
Guardian just bled it for everything it
was worth and it was one of those cases
where here's our data show us please
where we went wrong no we'd rather just
you know make this into a bit of a gong
show in the courts so I'm pretty sure
this is all going to blow over but there
you go so we start thinking about how
much effort and money time capital has
gone into all of these labels and think
about what kind of return have we gotten
as consumers have they gotten in terms
of trying to meet their mandate of
presumably trying to effect positive
change miss a huge wake-up call um top
the five leading labels or organic
labels you know there might be some
informative value there by and large
we're looking at at less than a ten
percent a ten percent game mm usually
quite a bit less than ten percent
organic labels tend to be more so than
others ideologically driven and so they
tend not to be focused more on you know
how easy is it to adapt to this how is
it to meet these standards whereas the
industry driven labels tend to tend to
be a little bit more adoptable if that's
if that's a word but it does you know
being more adoptable also you know means
by and large setting the bar lower and
that brings up a an interesting kind of
question is it is it preferable if
you're trying to effect positive change
is it preferable to set a more modest
bar that will have greater buy-in from
the industry or is it preferable to set
a higher bar knowing that you're only
going to be able to to certify
a small section of the industry but hope
that that creates either the carrot or
the stick I guess depending on how you
look at it to bring the rest of it up
you know and this is this is this debate
is is is ongoing within the the
sustainable seafood world as we as we
speak and I don't see it being resolved
categorically one way or one way or the
other but it does present a bit of a
problem and initially we only we will be
able to find me as much as Marks and
Spencers and we're hoping our whole
foods is up there they're the only two
retailer this there's plenty of retailer
retailer and labels out there but we
were not able to find any with the
exception of these two that actually had
any kind of metrics associated with them
we were going to do good yeah we're
going to try our best you know this is
literally the kind of thing that that is
characterized a lot of these labels so
when we started out with 36 of these
labels we started with 36 to set the
groundwork for you know the peer review
for Gabby which we include in the gap e
but then we also came back and reassess
them for the purposes of this
benchmarking we started it with 36 but
only 20 of them actually had anything we
could work with right the other 16 were
vapor standards they're there some you
know that we looked at had a web page
there was a web page and that's all
there was but you know they did have
labels on product in stores it was it
was eye-opening right and so a couple of
couple of things fallout from this yeah
we the fact that that we could only
actually measure something interesting
with a little over half of these labels
was telling in and of itself the the
market is rife with lots of what I would
call greenwashing simply because there's
an economic incentive to do it the
the fact that the vast majority of these
kinds of initiatives the labels deal in
qualitative or best practices kinds of
objectives presents a problem in terms
of how do you actually assess if you're
you're gaining anything if this is this
is yielding any kind of net positive
movement and you know this is something
I just keep coming back to because I
think it's just the elephant in the room
is the issue of scale right as we I
think this was included last last week
you know we've got the situation where
norway score 72 on a per metric ton
that's because Atlanta examine is an old
industry they've they've kind of worked
out a lot of the bugs they may started
producing a product that can be done
relatively efficiency relatively
efficiently which is to say it you can
produce a good amount of product for a
relatively modest amount of input that
doesn't have anything to do with the
ecological performance but when we start
looking at the you know the scale of
production in Norway and the impact that
production has on the coast that's a
pretty big problem in and I don't know
that this that slide come out last year
app I mean that what's going on in China
is just astounding and you know it
really makes a little difference if we
start cherry-picking this farm that far
more nurse start looking at per metric
ton performances when you've got this
scale of of activity going on you know
we we definitely need to be adjusting
the the per metric ton criterion looking
at at it from a cumulative standpoint so
up until this points in this part of our
story it's a pretty dire situation that
we've got an overall performance you
know even the top performing products in
the global aquaculture Millie's
mariculture world they are sitting at a
sea right that's the top of the class is
getting a C grade and then it gets
progressively worse from there which
generates a lot of angst in the part of
consumers and so we have this seafood
the sustainable seafood industry pop up
with all of their labels the majority of
which mean very little
what are we going to do well there's a
lot of technological advances going on
in this world we've got integrated multi
topic aquaculture in the top the top
left there and and I'm sure most of you
are aware this where we have the target
species being grown above other
potentially harvestable species that
consume the by-products of your target
species we have solid walls so typically
floating not cages not open net pens but
solid walled enclosure is where we can
grow our fish we have flow through
systems and we have so-called wraps or
recirculating aquaculture systems and
these are seeing these are all in
various stages of development some much
further ahead than others and are very
quietly sort of reshaping the entire
aquaculture world and this is val ITA
she's a graduate student while she's
almost not a graduate student anymore
she's all just on the verge of defending
her work and is actually a an ex
princeton rower but we'll talk about her
work here anyway and she's looking at a
farm level assessment of these
technologies so so this says the
unfortunate name of flappy which was
based on Gabby which was based on epi so
this is the grand child perhaps would
that be great grandchild of epi and so
those work is taking the gap e framework
tweaking it again rather than looking at
species in country but now looking at it
at the farm level and in the intervening
time well that floppy was was released
monterey bay aquarium which does the
Seafood Watch program which is i think
well it's not even arguably it is the
leading brand within the sustainable
seafood world took Gabby and then
completely retool their whole assessment
package that is now on a 100-point scale
and its performance oriented and it has
all the same kinds of indicators that
were looking at and so it's been Gabi
eyes and so what Val has done is taken
the MBA tool and then we think made some
improvements to it which we're going to
hopefully talk them into adopting but in
the meantime use this new farm level
tool to assess those technologies in the
same way that we did with the the the
label benchmarking we're now saying what
kind of value-added are we looking at if
we produce product particularly salmon
because this where you know most of the
world is focused on in this part of the
world growing salmon these different
technologies what can we expect to
achieve using these these technologies
and so here's our load spider diagram
again and we've got so again to
reacquaint you with the names
recirculating aquaculture systems imta
integrated multi trophic so the not
polyculture but an integrated multi
trophic aquaculture system open net
pencil conventional open net pens in the
green then flow through and solid side
and we did some statistical analyses and
said well you know geez some of those
lines look like they're following very
similar paths statistically speaking
these don't look like they're all
independent of each other in terms of
their performance and you know it turns
out they're not that I MTA the multi
trophic and conventional net pens almost
no difference all right and you can
follow those two those two lines around
and see it the only difference is a
slight bump in an improvement for IM
TANF fluid so too for the flow through
the solid side very similar in terms of
performance and statistically not
differentiate able and so when we
collapse them down we get a slightly
more digest
able series of plots where we've got the
net pen IMTA in red solid and flow
through in green and rats by itself
clearly the standout performer where
things really put laps down on top of
each other though is feet and a couple
of spots we'll get into that but I
wanted to focus on on this rass or
recirculating aquaculture we can tell
you I know you're interested in IMT and
we think we can talk about that but I so
far wrasses is kind of the the potential
real star that isn't gotten a lot of
attention yet so I thought it was worth
kind of going into it a little bit these
are recirculating systems that are that
are absolutely closed right so there are
one hundred percent bio-secure right we
are done with diseases and parasite
transfers to two wild systems because
they're bio-secure we've also eliminated
the need for the vast majority of
antibiotics parasit asides obviously
antifouling solving the nasty chemicals
there's farms now operating that are one
hundred percent recirculation so in
other words when the fish are harvested
at the end of the production cycle
they're removed from the same water they
started that production cycle in a year
14 months earlier this huge
technological advancement because the
system the environment in which these
fish are kept is so tightly monitored
you can have densities that are about
seven times higher than conventional net
pens not only can you have in fact the
fish respond better there's a growing
amount of literature that is documenting
this that when when looking at stress
hormones cortisol etc in these fish the
level of these indicator physiological
chemicals are actually superior
and the flow through or not the flow
through and their ass systems that in
conventional net pens up to one hundred
percent water circulation so removing
the requirement or the the externality
of water in the equation so in
conventional net pens you know yes
they're sitting in what in the water but
the whole business model is predicated
upon lots of current moving in fresh
oxygenated and in the case of salmon
cold water and then moving out oxygen
depleted nutrient-rich water out of that
out of that system and then all of the
sort of allied issues that go along with
in a particular system that is running
then this is 101 of these one hundred
percent research systems in Nova Scotia
Canada the effluent because there's no
liner but there's no chemicals involved
in the entire production cycle the the
outflow be organic output of this of
this farm is is you know meets all of
your organic standards out there and is
truck down the road literally just down
the road to an organic farm and sold so
there's actually additional value
streams that are available to this this
kind of production that might not be
available to to other forms again
because the the environment is tightly
controlled at an absolute and invariant
Optima the growth cycle is decreased so
you can move more product through your
farm per unit time than you would be
able to do in an open net pen situation
and because it's a completely closed
system and can be taken literally
anywhere but with salmon there are
systems now that have grown salmon in
completely fresh you don't need salt
water to grow salmon
in brackish so mix of both and then
complete marine and so therefore that
opens up the possibility it's a pilot
study proving that this type of system
should be amenable to any of the
400-plus species that are currently
produced in aquaculture systems and this
is potentially the most exciting aspect
of this set of technology or
technologies that form rest is that no
longer is this necessarily the context
of the salmon farm at least you know in
British Columbia where this photo was
taken out in the middle of nowhere you
can now take the production of the fish
and move them into if not the center of
urban zones at least on the periphery of
urban zones where the fish are going to
be consumed because when we're talking
about embedded energy and this is always
the knock against wrasse and to a
certain set these solid sided systems is
that they're much more energy intensive
fair enough but by far away 90 get my
numbers right ninety-four percent of the
embedded energy in the in the typical
salmon product is in its transportation
not in its production and so well yes
and you know we can go back to those
spider diagrams look at energy again yes
these these raft systems do have a
higher energy requirement because you're
now looking at seven times the density
and you're removing ninety-four percent
well if you're bringing them close to
where they're going to be consumed up to
ninety four percent of the embedded
energy the total energy equation drops
precipitously down and it gets them out
of my coast which I like the most yeah
this water is anything but pristine this
would and that but I don't think we're
talking but you different kinds of
pristine this water is full of pathogens
is full of disease is full of wild
salmon it's full of potentially noxious
chemicals although you know in this
particular context probably not it could
be though when when we're talking about
these wrath systems i think you know we
need to separate the wrath system from a
lot of these other land based systems
which are not research systems having a
research system means that you are
controlling to a very fine degree all
parameters of water quality so even if
you're starting with if you're starting
with water that a human can drink which
i think is a fair assumption your water
quality is going to be superior in the
case of raising fish than anything
you're going to get sort of ambient
water in the marine environment what
makes the wrasse technology viable is
that it maintains that quality through
the production cycle and this is not
this is not a trivial technical
consideration these this is a this is
state-of-the-art water quality
scientists going on the point on which
I'll get to in a moment is that it's
matured to the point where we can now
well not we can they are producing
product bringing it to market for a
fryer only a small fraction increase
over conventionally produced product but
because you can you're removing the cost
of transport or potentially so right the
actual economics then switch into favor
of the system so I don't
I don't think I'm when you say it's not
for established on a charm answering the
question when you say what are you
thinking of particularly you fill them
up and you're done and so and then they
they drain with each cohort moving so
you bring up you bring a cohort to to
market drain Phil I that's what I mean
it you know you could have there there
there actually you move them you sort
them and you move them from tank to tank
and so on whole you're you're by the end
of production cycle you've you've
switched out the water 11 time yeah oh I
because because because ninety-four
percent I mean if of course it makes are
we talking frozen product or fresh
product are we talking you know what
distance are we traveling what's your
words that words are starting from where
is it ending up all these things come
into the mix but the bottom line is the
vast majority of embedded energy in any
fish product is in the transportation
regardless of all of those those things
and so if you are going to bring the
production site alongside the
consumption site you're removing the
vast amount of embedded energy even
though your production system may have a
nominal increase in energy when we start
looking at the cumulative again right
cumulative the the math is absolutely
yeah
yeah sure
right really in terms of the product
itself is you know if if you don't
pigment the flesh it's going to come out
a dull grey at the end yes it's still
farm salmon yeah and in fact as you know
well actually I don't want to give give
it away but I mean the feed I mean it's
still a farm salmon in in every way
except possibly that it has been grown
in as optimal and environment as is
possible and if that conveys into either
a nutrient or flavor profile change it
will do so in a positive way but i
wouldn't expect there to be a
significant alteration either okay so
that's what we're talking about so if we
moved all production current production
let's just play God for a minute and
we're going to move all current
production of salmon currently in
conventional net pens we're going to put
them into a Roth system right and we
capped impacts at what Val estimated
that for the 2012 to accumulate of
impacts of farm salmon the question then
becomes how much more salmon might we be
able to produce well capping impacts at
current levels that make sense
essentially we can double production
so there are a whole lot of these
systems out there yet there are a number
of British Columbia there are a number
being being built or planned in the u.s.
there are some in Europe China's looking
at this big time this slide is actually
at a date with regard to China already
know so this is definitely where the
industry is heading the interesting
thing from my point of view is that it
removes the vast majority of excuses for
why the issues are the way they are with
farm salmon it's going to be very
interesting to to push politicians and
bureaucrats who have built up a certain
amount of political momentum in
explaining away the escapes see life's
diseases organic pollution inorganic
pollution etc etc as you know various
various forms of the cost of doing
business sort of argument right this is
clearly no longer the cost of doing
business there are ways of doing
business that remove all of these things
and potentially potentially improve yeah
you guys decide whichever
the reason why it's not now because yeah
I have there is huge resistance within
the established aquaculture the salmon
farming community to do this there are
marine harvest is playing playing with
one you know rd farm only because i
think it has to be to be able to point
to it and say look at where you know
we're trying we're trying this out all
of this though is is being all of these
farms listed here are being being
bankrolled by venture capitalists who
are trying to achieve a political end as
well as a financial end yep the biggest
them I'm again I'm I don't want to speak
for this because it is you know
obviously a little bit more complicated
than I've I've elated out the the
biggest determinant though of your
financial efficacy is the cost of your
electricity so if you locate your
operation on the grid where electricity
is is a reasonable price that is going
to change your bottom-line dramatically
good idea is the biggest right that's
the biggest determinant of your
competitive power against your your your
your competitors in the marketplace
which your conventional net pens the one
thing it's not completely Rosie right
these are still carnivorous animals and
as we saw in the assessments the feed
issue right is very little difference
between rats and well if there's very
little difference among all of these
systems there is there's modest increase
in your feed conversion ratio or your
your how much fish you got to put in to
get your fish out because the system is
optimized but it's a modest increase and
so when we start talking about well we
could double our production right of
farm salmon this ignores one of the
overriding most important issue
which is the reliance on these marine
organisms to actually drive your
production and you know I'd never get
sick of this slide oh you don't that you
know when we look at top 10 Fisheries in
the world right by weight only three of
them are fisheries that we actually
directly consumed the products of the
rest go to reduction fisheries thanks
for feeding things like farm salmon and
shrimp and chickens etc so agriculture
currently consumes half of the fish meal
produce better these fisheries and
others an eighty percent of the fish oil
now I understand next up in this series
is this idea where we're going to take
GM yeast write and produce omega-3 oils
to feed to salmon so it's a good idea
they'll be interesting to see how this
all plays out at the same time though we
have aqua bounty who is about to get FDA
approval for their genetically modified
salmon which you know as those two fish
up their siblings one is Jack the
modified ones not you can probably tell
who's who fed the same the same diet etc
and so there's been huge push back on
the GM salmon and the fact that this is
about to become ready for for human
consumption in the US and then by virtue
Canada and probably at uk2 and you know
I don't see the same kinds of things the
kind of rebuttals going on for this
product here in fact it may be is
because i live in bc i don't know but to
me salmon is five percent flesh and fins
it's ninety-five percent rivers
estuaries and oceans and you know i
think it's it's it's about time we
started asking you know when is a salmon
no longer a salmon think of think of the
trajectory of this story we started out
with wild salmon fisheries particularly
in
atlantic salmon or in North Atlantic
which which claps and in response to
that diminishing before they collapsed
we had the the advent of commercial
salmon farming to try and take the
pressure off of wild stocks so the story
goes and that industry increased and
improved and found deficiencies and grew
even more in groove in more grew and
more to the point when we actually
started eating more and more more salmon
the Atlantic salmon stocks and to a
certain cut the Pacific salmon stocks to
continue to collapse we haven't kept our
salmon consumption consistent and just
traded farm for wild we continue to eat
the while we're just eating more and
more farm so now farm salmon has
generated all these issues diseases and
parasites and organic pollution and
escapes and all of these things so now
we've got this technology min to these
land-based pens and it's going to create
panacea now we can double our production
of Salmonella can eat more and more
salmon hey I'm thinking would you know
or what is the what's the the question
we're trying to answer here or is it the
fact that that everybody in the world
has to eat salmon is that the problem I
think we've lost track of what is the
issue we're trying to solve right and so
there's there's a and and I don't want
and I'm not trying to set up your your
your guests from from Chile for dubai
dubai it's it's but I think it's worth
stepping back a minute and asking what
is it that we're actually trying to do
because if it's if it's about generating
revenue that absolutely you will make
more money converting an Taveta into
salmon right you will feed far fewer
people by doing that and you can even
start feeding them little yeast pills
right that's all fine and dandy because
you will make money and there's nothing
wrong with that but let's be clear about
what our objectives are
that's why would encourage you to step
back and kind of consider these these
larger larger scale issues and problems
and and opportunities so with that all
I'll end and take any more questions if
there are any
well it's an aggressive really
interesting question i think you know in
the early days the farm stand